So we verified a listing is within
a half an hour walk from work.
Doesn't make me take a ferry and we're
able to verify that our pancake house,
gelateria, school, or
hospital is in the area.
But after a search query turns up those
results we want to see more about those
places in our potential
new neighborhood.
Luckily the places library
is a ridiculously large
database full of useful tidbits
about the world around us.
Places returned in both
our auto complete and
search box have unique
identifiers called place IDs.
You should be aware that you can
pass them just like latlongs and
many of the services such as
distance matrix and directions APIs.
Place IDs are the keys that you get back
tons of details about an establishment
or location.
When we get the list of results from
our search box, we get place IDs for
all of them.
Let's take a look at a few
examples of using the place IDs
in the place details web service to see
what kind of details are available.
We already have a place
ID here to test out.
We'll be getting the place IDs within
our site from our search box or
text search query.
But for the web service request,
we can get place IDs from the places,
text, nearby or radar searches.
Check out the link in the instructor
notes for how to do that.
We need to use the place
IDs to search for
place details which is the demonstration
that we're about to do.
Again, I'm specifying that I'm doing
a place detail search here and
that I want the response in JSON format.
I'm passing in a place ID and
my API key.
Here's the response that we get back for
the Google Sydney office.
I'm going to minimize the address
components and the geometry.
We can see here that we get back an
international phone number, the name for
the place, some photos, a rating,
not sure where those .5 points went,
lots of reviews, and the type.
So we can tell this is an establishment,
which means it's a business.
All of these photos have photo
reference IDs, seen here.
We can build another simple URL
to use the photo reference IDs
using an API key and
a photo reference parameter, and a wif.
This time I'm making
a places photo request.
Again I specify a width,
the photo reference ID
that I got back from the place
details request, and my API key.
That's the places photo that we were
given in our place details request.
Let's do another place ID as an example.
This is a great little coffee shop.
You may or may not have heard of it.
We can see that this is the Starbucks
on Broadway in the city.
Now we can see some pretty useful stuff.
Operating hours are really useful for
one thing.
We'll use these on our site later when
we will get place detail results.
Notice that we get back for
display purposes text, but also granular
data of the periods when it's open.
Again we get back the photos.
We also again get back the rating and
reviews.
So for example if I wanted to limit
my results to things open for
certain hours or
above a certain rating I could do that.
If you're making a restaurant reviewer
search app these things could be
really important to you.
Let's get back to our site.
So we're already getting back all the
place IDs when we do the text search or
the search box query.
So let's add an OnClick event
on the markers that appear
that'll display some placed
details about each marker.
Remember, we need the places
library loaded to do this.
We already included it in order to
use auto-complete, and search box.
We're going to add to our create
markers for places function.
For each place marker that we create,
we're going to add an event listener
to call a get details function.
We're going to create a single info
window here that we'll share between
the different place markers that we only
have set of place details open at once.
And then we'll add our event listener
for a click event on the marker.
This will call a get
place details function,
passing in the marker which is this and
the placeInfoWindow.
Let's define that now.
Our getPlace details function is
going to use the placeID to execute
a placeDetailSearch.
And then it's going to display a bunch
of that information in an info window
above the place marker.
We'll create a new places service and
use the getDetails method.
Passing in the place ID which
we set as the marker ID before.
We'll get back the results.
Check that the status is okay.
And then parse through all that
neat data that we saw before
in the web service call.
We'll put all of this data into
the info window that we create,
including the first photo
reference that we get.
Remember, not every place ID will return
all of the details that we
saw in the web service calls.
Some of them may not have opening hours,
some of them may not have
a phone number, et cetera.
So we have to check for the existence of
each of these pieces of data before we
actually display it in the info window.
Let's test this out.
Let's click on some of these
markers to get more results.
We can see the place name,
the formatted address,
the phone number, the operating
hours and a nice little thumbnail.
A 24 hour IHOP!
Jackpot.
All right, so
I think this is really
going to help our users.
At this point they'd be able to find the
places of interest in the neighborhoods
that they could potentially live in.
Let's review our places
API skills in a quiz.